Charles Dave it's good to see you here
on the program I'm doing well before we
do in the full ash are you coming back
are you just with Gruden I saw that you
and Gruden are tight you want to prove
you want to patrol the secondary for
mayor you remember you remember I never
made it in the first place so you can't
come back to something you didn't make
in the first place but even before we
get to this yes sir
Johnny Manziel double-secret probation
in Canada what the hell right I mean
right I mean Dean wormer came in and
dropped the bomb and johnny was like I
was on double-secret probation was on
and then to find out that they said you
guys are with anyone like you're
off-limits there you are out of Canada's
gotta get extradition well-done it's
taking place what the heck I know all
right I don't know and I can only hope
it's not something that is please now
please I've always taken the approach
for Johnny yeah Manziel oh I met like
literally for two seconds once I've
always taken the approach that there's
nothing funny and that there was I think
I'm what I say on the show a couple
years ago that there's got to be
somebody out there looking out for him
what he's coming out of like one oak you
know what I mean right at 1:00 in the
morning 2:00 in the morning like look
out form don't take him there don't go
in there but but you but you know that
that rarely works with anyone if we
think about just being real quick on
this right sure Josh Hamilton and all of
his struggles he had some big moments
right but how many times did he escape
the person he was supposed to be with
and they couldn't find him and then when
they found him it wasn't pretty right
right remember pac-man when he's with
the Cowboys and had the guy within 24/7
and cacnea gets in trouble throwing down
with the guy right next to him so at the
end of the day you can just stay in
trouble this week I know and he doesn't
even have a guy now but he had the guy
remember Jerry had the guy within 24/7
pack didn't even like the guy right but
not he didn't even escape on that one
remember Pat got in trouble wasn't it a
fight or something like that and the guy
was right there so so the idea that hey
if you have that handler that's that's a
great thought process but
dudes are gonna do it they're gonna do
it charles davis here on the Rich Eisen
show and we're part of the on-field
drills tomorrow 9:00 a.m. right there on
the NFL Network we've got a meeting
later on today at Lucas Oil good times
coming up what do you make of Murray not
throwing same thing I've made of just
about everyone not throwing it it's a
bummer for us it is it's a bummer for us
but Sam Donald didn't throw last year
went third Andrew Luck didn't throw one
Andrew Luck didn't throw I mean it's a
it's a story for us and I know that a
different teams will tell us well we'd
like to see guys compete we'd like to
see this we'd like to see that but when
it comes down to it if they really like
together gonna take him on their
throwing it's just a bummer for us
because it's great TV and it's great
it's a great way to see him with
everyone else at the same time and say
hey that's what it looks like and you
know Mayock said it this week when he
was it's still still a little strange
right but you know he's consistent so
him saying I want to know what makes a
kid tick yeah remember you know the joy
Russell Pro - everyone was drooling all
over and he's like hold on I don't know
if this guy really wants to play
football so Kyler Mari I think clearly
by telling the A's were done paying back
whatever needs to be paid back to the
A's and making some sort of agent change
yep is moving completes a lot of seven
moving a lot of Earth so he's told you
that he told okay so even him not
throwing here he can't say well you're
being inconsistent he loved football so
much and yet your passion will not bring
you to actually throw so then the
question is why not throw and now I'm
already hearing into that void comes
back well he's two bills he's 207 pounds
and he's never been 207 pounds
definitely not running at 207 he
shouldn't and he's definitely not
throwing it to o some new this this was
just simply to win today so but what did
to win the combat some point he's gonna
have March 3rd right do you think at the
pro day he's he'll still be 207 no no no
no what will and won't no he'll be in
the 190s so then why get up to 207 at
all what's the that one I don't figure
Ridge the one two
all he had to do to win today was we
stand there would be five ten and one X
because once he did that who you are
right hey you know remember remember
lean on me Joe Clark right he made you
and I'm telling you rich if my kids
could hear this now they would fall over
in an absolute embarrassment but they
would shake their heads because I have
co-opted one of Joe Clark's great lines
in there when they were telling him all
the things he had to do and he said I
don't have to do anything but be black
and die and I use that line all the time
around my house and my kids are just
like oh my god all Cuyler Murray had to
do was be 510 and 1 eighths today that's
all he had to do he'd have to be 207 to
me okay some teams may say they'd like
to see that Russell Wilson I believe
weighed in at two oh four or five times
to get to that right matter but but
calimary has heard the discussion of how
slight he is the hits he's going to take
he's he's too little for this and I
don't know if he and his his his
administration decided that this was the
way to go but he won at 5:10 and 1h rich
which is incredible and the reason I say
incredible is timeline of football if we
had said this ten years ago that a guy
would measure in at five ten and 1/8 and
we'd be going okay we don't many more
questions about that we don't be looking
at each other we'd say five ten and 1/8
he's too little to play quarterback in
this league we were saying that in the
home now first segment right crazy
here we are 510 and 1/8 he's now Paul
Bunyan it's amazing how that one for him
today he went he won the combine today
DJ came on the show yesterday and said
that he got he gave Russell Wilson
coming out of Wisconsin a second round
gray and by hearing everybody say he's
too short he's to this he's to that he
got scared and he gave him a third round
grade and that's where Pete Carroll
wooden rabbit and we had p.m. our number
one he said that it was difficult to get
through the status-quo
evaluation he had asked him who the
status quo was and he basically laughed
he goes well it was me it was the setup
that we had here was me like even he had
to get out of his own head he gave his
own head to do to do it and so that's
why I was telling you know Brockman will
stay here Charles David
the Rich Eisen show and he's been saying
for the last several days that what's
the difference between 5 10 and 1/8 + 5
9 and 3/4 and I'm like well the
difference is do the math yeah that's
the difference and that they'd be able
to say he's 510 and 1/8 any sort of cya
moment that a Scout can have with a
general manager and general manager with
an owner to say hey 510 was kind of a
magic number industry-wide and he hid
that box so don't blame me that is kind
of crucial in order for a team to go
ahead and say we're taking this great
great point and here's the other part
for me is Eddie LeBaron because you know
I always will go go way deep right
you're in that's why we this is the old
gents nacho right so Eddie LeBaron had
well over 100 starts at what five seven
five eat whatever he was right he was
the ultimate outlier then came Fran
Tarkenton whose first coach norm Van
Brocklin the Dutchman in the Hall of
Fame as a quarterback used to tell him
Francis you only leave the pocket out of
sheer fright drove him crazy that he
would scramble retired as the all-time
leading passer in NFL history 510
another outlier but in recent years if
we're gonna add your Brees in yeah I did
Drew Brees this is great cuz we're
talking about the timeline yeah Fran
Tarkenton was still the outlier they
still weren't looking for Fran Tarkenton
to come into the league they were still
bypassing the Fran Tarkenton that were
coming into the league and going for the
6-3 6-4 guy could throw it through a
wall but take about recent years right
in our timeframe now with the breeze
Wilson Mayfield have now to your point I
think and let me see if I won't make
sure I'm hitting it right now put words
in your mouth Ridge that GM now has that
carte blanche to actually be wrong but
take calimary meaning if Colin Murray
doesn't become a superstar you don't
know your job status isn't automatically
jeopardized because you took the 510 gap
well the one you're taking the 510 guy
the people are saying maybe the best
quarterback in the draft right and the
fact that Mayfield broke a ceiling of
yes well by being first overall at that
height yes less than 6 1 and maybe was
the best rookie in the league last year
depending on who you want to ask well
he's the best rookie quarterback
right no doubt about it only transport
he transformed a franchise Daquan was
the only one that could be denied the
award this year at the NFL honors we
mentioned Flutie in this whole mix and
came along too soon right came home to
Sue's Heisman Trophy winner but one of
the best players in college football
coming out like don't you think Flutie
would be you spent time another Navigant
sure okay you spend time with him Prince
have you ever seen Doug Flutie
athletically outside of football
no guys let me tell you something no
kidding he's the dude that you pick in
the pickup game and then you stay on the
court through lunch he's going to win
those games for you I'll give you a very
quick anecdote I was hosting the College
Football Hall of Fame ceremonies and sat
back whenever is still in South Bend and
he went in one year and I'm hosting
ceremonies and they used to have this
little like pickup game with all the
honorees going in now something that was
a little sketchy because there were a
couple guys here with Keynes and I mean
you know it depended on their age and
and what had happened to them playing
Doug Flutie was on that field like a
young Colt he was diving for passes and
making catches he was intercepting balls
he was doing things he's that guy that
if he came around now we'd be evaluating
him a lot like Kyler Murray armed
athletic ability and concrete the plays
all of those things he came along too
soon and when Mike Ditka called him
Bambi I was in but dick is from a
different different era but you remember
what he said it's like looking like look
in the eyes of Bambi and again now
missing the outlier but remember every
time he got an opportunity didn't he
produce mm-hmm but no one believed it
for long you know who you know who he's
the version of now Case Keenum
when Case Keenum would produce even
after taking the Vice in a state
championship game Mike Zimmer was like
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
let him go 2000 2007 foody Hall of Fame
college yeah I wish you guys had seen it
it was unbelievable they don't make just
Flutie flakes for nothing Michael Vick
too soon Michael Vick remember Michael
Vick's speed and electricity was so
dazzling plus the way he threw the
football that ball came off his hand
like a flick remember
Ludi was much more of a a full arm
motion guy so it wasn't the same look I
mean Vic when he threw a think about in
your head Chris when you saw a victim to
pocket Netflix and also in 50 yards
downfield it was a dart right under the
national championship game when he was a
freshman and and if we look but we mind
do you mind looking up the numbers he
put up that day because in our mind
he was a 300-yard thrower that night in
150 yard Runner and I'll bet you the
numbers aren't close to that but it felt
that way watching the ballgame well he's
the first quarterback to win a road
playoff start in Green Bay failed and
remember him running that day and plus
Michael Vick was built solid you know he
was six foot in thicker and I'm hearing
Murray's a version of him yeah I mean
it's amazing because if he is drafted
where he is then the transformations
come he comes from a guy who's less than
six foot one to be drafted first overall
first since victor be that and now the
next year a Heisman Trophy winner
selected in the top five ten if ya at
five ten and an eight do you think
Arizona goes ahead and does that I mean
how real is that gonna be in two months
I had been adamantly no no no no in
someone I respect greatly said to me
today they took a big swing for the
fences with Kliff Kingsbury hmm might as
well go all for it
don't think it's out of line Sandro's
and elsewhere I mean don't think it's
out of line Jay gave us the scenario Sen
Rose and elsewhere for first round
selection this year yeah and you you use
that to supplement whatever you would be
supplementing then you take your first
round your first pick of the second
round in front and send that to
Pittsburgh for Antonio Brown you got an
antonio brown larry fitzgerald charlie
kirk david johnson
I mean Cristian Cristian Kirk geez I've
been reading too much politic which
incur for with calamari for clippings
Bernie Johnson and let's roll well it's
it's not it's not an out of line
scenario I would not have gone that way
up until these recent days and when he
was stood up and was 510 in an eighth
and now it opens up the door even more
in terms of that I
in it what's interesting to me about is
just yesterday I was walking with an
offensive coordinator in the lake and we
were having the discussion about Cuyler
Murray and the big thing was you know it
reads five zero and then that next
number was gonna be the key for was it a
nine
was it a one first you can get to ten I
said what if that number is eight woof
it's five zero eight whatever and the
office corner said someone will still
take him in the first round because they
believed they could I said okay so that
was that that told me a lot right there
what if a punter showed up the combine
and said I will not pend here how great
Y will be measured I will be measured
and then we're all talking about foot
size no no I mean I can't wait to talk
about that was Pat not much fun that
would be for the punter to decline to
punt
I refuse to pond and then go to the
podium I will not pend that happened you
would be at the podium without precedent
I'd be demanding I'm not coming to your
pro day to watch you punted Mike Tomlin
which is Mike Tomlin common I by the way
he sent out a nice tweet about the run
retron this is gonna be fun and then of
course you are the voice of Ron rich Ron
I'm fired you you got you do the samel
cam part of I'm fired up about it
watching uh you know watching me get a
house by all the other prospects here
and listening to Dion laugh the
environment Dion loves it
sorry this Big Finish he loves on the
way here Brockman saw me facetiming with
my children in my own yeah my wife as
you heard as we pulled in Suzie was did
not have a guest for her official Lakers
podcast right fresh off the Lakers with
a big win over the pelicans a big win
they tried to I think she did get a
guest okay who is it well I got a text
saying I might leave you for Chris
Webber is that okay wow wow wow I mean
you have to say that's okay yep say okay
no no just like she's clearly a tribute
to Michigan men but clearly but you know
what you say the best I know what she
said though she loves Brady she's
leaving me for soon yeah when she said I
might leave you for Chris wherever you
said timeout Oh
sorry Wow good nel fit your baseball
point with Carla Marie listen we've all
done our homework so that I don't think
this is original or whatever everyone
wants to do it but I wanted to find out
the true measure of this baseball
football thing with Kyler Murray so I've
talked with five different organizations
and the people I've talked with have
ranged from scout through GM and asked
what was the evaluation your
organization had on Kyler Murray coming
out did you expect him go in the first
round all of them said there was
rumblings that he would go in the first
round all five that I talked to said we
were not one of those teams the second
thing is okay what range did you have
amongst the five teams the consensus was
rounds three and four some said
potential to some said all the way
through five okay I said what were the
what were the issues that you would have
and why you wouldn't have taken him in
the first round and they said because
you know this is gonna blow you away
because they all said the same thing he
throws the heck out of the football but
all of us and all five of them told me
that they rated his arm his average in
baseball which is stunning to me
considering the way we watch him throw
the football average and as an arm
that's what all five told me and here's
the other part small right handed hitter
who struck out over fifty times last
year even though he hit 296 they worry
about that because they you know you
want that left handed hitter with the
step and a half closer to first base etc
etc etc contact all the other stuff but
the all five said we understand why
Oakland did it because Billy Beane is
Billy Beane and he tends to Zig when
other zag and so on and so forth
but they were all excited about the
possibility of him playing bass playing
baseball because they said we don't get
these athletes anymore they all go to
football or basketball or somewhere else
they wanted to see how that would have
developed so they understood it but they
just said that first round was too rich
for them but they thought that one or
two teams
might take the shot and Oakland was a
team that did it but they were really
surprised top ten so that's that's all
I'm saying for him football is the
absolute right choice because the other
part of it is we never give enough
credence to just how hard it is to be a
baseball player we just don't give it
think about the minors think about
working your way up thinking about doing
it that way as opposed to being the man
on the football team and being the
starting quit he's gonna make more money
playing football well I just hope he's
ready for the scrutiny I think he is
it's not just it's not just that what's
going down with me and obviously being a
big-time college quarterback at a
big-time college program when you're
starter and being the big-time Heisman
Trophy winner the you know and I've got
90 seconds left here let's be honest
this draft without him is not it was
defensive tackles and it's not as
exciting no it's not
no II transform the dream you are going
to between now and last Thursday in
April in Nashville calimary Calipari
everything everything about it in your
in your movie draft day when Kevin
Costner wrote down yeah what did he
write on that slip of paper Mac oh no no
matter whom Vontae Mack no matter what
do you miles away Schuyler Murray no
matter what that's that's going to be
the conversation but I think he's gonna
be okay remember the old man was a
baseball player came back and played
football that was a big time stud at
Texas A&M uncle Calvin Murray major
league baseball player he's got the
right support around him they understand
what it takes to be this type of an
athlete what you're going to go through
I know it's different 2019 but I think
the kid's gonna be okay but I guess
right now like what does it matter he's
207 if he's got any we've got but he's
only gonna get up to 207 just to whatnot
run and not throw that's in the same way
that why would he come on a show at the
Super Bowl without being able to answer
the question that you know he's gonna be
asked and you didn't have a plan for
that and it's just that's just again yep
it's it's part of the process for
parties to evaluate but all he had to do
was be 510 and 1/8 and you did it check
that box I will see you at the meeting I
look forward to it take care now that's
Charles Davis the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern
on audience